i want to thank the president for his
words
i'm very happy
you all know how was my exit from
barcelona
it's been a very hard moment
after so many years
it was a difficult change after so many
times
the moment i arrived here
i felt very happy
and i really want to begin
the training sessions
i really wanted to be quick
i'm really enjoying my time in paris
since the first minute
my family my people
but really
is to begin the training sessions i want
to
work with the staff and with my
teammates and begin this new moment of
my life
i really want to thank the president and
leonardo and the whole club
for the way they received me
the first day after the press release in
barcelona
they really were quick in the
negotiations and it's been quite easy
actually
it was a very tricky situation and they
really solved problems
it was not easy and they did it well so
really thank you for that
i repeat but i'm very happy to be here
and uh
this will too
impatience
i think this club is really ready to
fight for all the trophies
this is my goal
i want to
keep growing
keep winning titles
that's why i come here to this club
i hope we can
make it happen i really want to thank
paris and
it's been all crazy my arrival
it was a surprise
thank you again for the way they
received me and i'm sure i'm going to
enjoy the time with this team and we are
going to fight
for the
aim of the club i really want to begin
now and thanks again to everybody
the president to leonardo and
thanks
psg and
thank you for
having me here
and i want to begin now